Transcriber: Hiba Alraisi
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
مساء الخير، شلونكم شخباركم؟
“باللهجة العراقية”
في الوقت الحالي أصبحنا نسمع عن
عالم ما قبل كورونا.. وعالم ما بعد كورونا.
فترة انتشرت ظاهرة انتشرت
على العالم أكبر، هدد البشرية أجمع
يعني تخيّل أن جيراني اللذين يسكنون بصفي،
لم أستطع أن اتعامل معهم ولا أزورهم.
التي بيننا كانت عبارة عن بوستات
تُعلَّق على الحيطان، على الجدران
“لا تُقبّلني ولا تصافحني
ولا تحضني ولا تسلم علي”
هذا كل الذي كان بيننا.
نزولنا للشارع..
صراحةً يعني لم نستطع النزول لنحافظ على
سلامتنا وسلامة الغير وليس فقط سلامتنا
ككُل
مرّت علينا أشهر وأسابيع وأيام
ونحن هذا حالنا
شعرنا أنه
يعني
كلنا غير متشافين، كلنا مرضى
أصبحت صلة التواصل بيننا
وبين أهلنا خارج البلاد
هي عبارة عن الإنترنت; طرق
التواصل الاجتماعي المعروفة بيننا
جميعنا حاصرتنا أفكار، مخاوف، أخطار
هددت نفسيتنا!
يعني تخيل أن أقرب الناس إليّ
في المنزل اذا ما كح أو عطس..
الكل يأخذ له زاوية.. ونقول له عقم يدك،
غسّل، إشرب فيتامين سي، قوّي مناعتك
سؤالي هُنا: إن شاء الله الأمور
عدت، تعافوا الناس وتعافينا؟
لكن السؤال هُنا:
هل تعافينا من داخلنا؟
تعافينا من السلبية التي شعرنا بها؟
تعافينا من شعورنا بالوحدة؟
من هنا سأبدأ وأحكي لكم
كوني ناشطة مهتمة بحقوق الإنسان
مشكلتي هُنا هي الإنسان ما قبل كورونا
لا يتمتع بالحساسية الكافية
بينه وبين الشعوب
وبين الغرباء عنه
أصبحت
هناك حدود وحواجز بيننا وبين الدول
جنسيات مختلفة
بين الأديان والأعراف والمذاهب
عدد كبير من الشعوب ليس لديها
استعداد لاستقبال اللاجئين
ليس لديها استعداد لتسمعهم..
ليس لديها استعداد أن تتقبلهم كلاجئين
ليس عن سوء نية.. لا على العكس
إنما الجميع لديه ما يكفيه من المشاكل
من ضغوط الحياة
يعني تعب هذه الحياة اليومية
والروتينية التي نمر بها
كل البلاد مرت..
بأزمة
ابدأها ببلدي الأم العراق
وأحييه من هُنا
وثم سوريا، اليمن، السودان، ليبيا
كلها بلاد عربية تنتمي إلى قُطر عربي واحد
كلها شاهدت
وكلها رأت
وتأذت  من الحروب
التي انجبرت عليها
لم ننتهي.. على العكس!
هنا بدأت معاناة اللاجئ
بدأ هنا التغيير من حال إلى حال
بدأ يواجه صعوبات،
بدأ يواجه اللغة،
بدأ يواجه العادات والتقاليد،
أمور كثيرة واجهتنا.
عانى اللاجئ هذه الفترة
وأنا شخصيا مطلعة على هذه الأمور
كوني كنت إحدى المتطوعات من
المفوضية السامية للأمم المتحدة
فترة النزوح كانت.. لا توصف
أعداد كثيرة من اللاجئين
كنا نخرج صباحًا، ليلًا، مساءًا
نريد إنهاء الملفات.. ولا تنتهي الملفات
إحنا شغالين لكن النازحين قادمون
حسنًا هؤلاء الذين سيأتون
إلى أين سنأخذهم؟
إتحدت كل المنظمات بهذه الفترة
جميعها جهود مشكورة، جميعها ساعدت
تُريد أن تخلّص اللاجئ من الأزمة
وتُخرجه من الذي كان يعيش فيه
خلال أعوام اللجوء،
صوت اللاجئ كان خافت غير مسموع
صوت اللاجئ كان..
مُتدني بسبب السكن والعمل
لماذا؟ ما السبب؟
سوف اوضح لكم
بالنسبة للاجئ.. لا يستطيع أن يشتغل
أو يدخل مدارس إذا لم تكن لديه إقامة
هنا اللاجئ بدأ يعاني
حسنًا..
ماذا سيفعل؟
إذا حصل على سكن لم يحصل على عمل
إذا حصل على عمل لم يحصل
على رعاية صحية
حسنًا كيف؟
هنا بدأت ايضًا معاناة
وسنعود إلى نفس الدائرة المغلقة للاجئ.
أعداد كبيرة من اللاجئين
لم نستطع..
إكمال أمورهم القانونية لأن
أمورهم شبه تعقدت بسبب الإقامة
كان العالم قبل كورونا يسمع
فئات مستضعفة من اللاجئين
أصحاب ضغوط نفسية وقهرية
بعد ظهور كورونا،
تم نسيان اللاجئ، تمّ ركنه
لماذا؟
بدأ الصوت الأعلى يخرج منه
بدأ الصوت الأقوى هو صوت
الإجراءات التحذيرية والاحترازية
ومعاناة الوباء التي يعيشها الناس
أحضر كحول، خُذ تعقيم،
واشتري فيتامين سي
والأزمة التي مررنا بها كلنا
سواء كُنَّا مصريين عراقيين سودانيين
جميعنا عانينا بهذا الشيء
سوف أحكي لكم عن تجربتي الشخصية
كوني مررت بها
وهي أزمة نفسية حادة
بصراحة ما زلت أعاني منها إلى الآن
كان زوجي مسافرًا
جاء من السفر بعد غياب سبعة أشهر
لم يرَ ابنائه
عندما جاء
بدأت عنده أعراض
شعر بأن به
سخونة وحرارة
قلنا تغيير جو، مطارات
مناخ دولة، من دولة لدولة،
حدث عنده تغيير
لكن لا والله لاحظت أن الأمور ازدادت
بدأ هنا يشعر بأن نفَسَهُ ضيّق
أصبحت أنا بين الشك اليقين
عزل نفسه هو مسكين،
عزل نفسه في غرفته
قال لكي لا أختلط
عندما بدأ نَفَسه يضيق
قلت أنه يجب عليّ عمل
فحص كورونا PCR
فأخذته وعملنا الفحص
وبالفعل ثبت أنّه مُصاب
وهنا بدأت عندي معاناة
للعلم.. أنا أم لبنتين اثنتين
يعني ليس لدي لا أخ
ولا أب
ولم يكن لدي من أهلي وأقاربي
أُناس يساعدونني
كنت أنا الوحيدة التي احتوت هذا البيت
عندما أخذته للمستشفى، تم حجره
بدأ الدكتور وقال لي تفضلي أخرجي
لأنك  أنتِ ملامسة
وأنا في طريقي للخروج
رأيته مستلقي على السرير
نظر إليّ بنظرةٍ
قال لي: “تغريد إنتبهي على البنات”
أنا هنا تدمرت
حسنًا
ماذا سيحصل بعدها؟
عالمٌ كبير يعني نقول كيف
لا ندري نحن ماذا سيحصل
أصبحت أشعر بأنني في عالم مجهول
إسودّت الدنيا بعيني
هذه الدنيا بكبرها وبحجمها
أصبحت عندي صفر،
بداية صفر نقطة سطر كما نقول
حسنًا أنا ماذا سأفعل؟
لا يوجد لديّ أحد
أتصل في أهلي فقط بالمكالمات
يقوون يصبّرون
يعني تخيلوا إن أنا جالسة في السيارة
ذاهبة للمستشفى
أقوي نفسي بنفسي،
“تغريد إنتي قوية،
تغريد لا تهزّك هذه الأشياء،
تغريد حافظي على بيتك،
حافظي على بناتك”
طلبوا مني في المستشفى بعض التحاليل
وإجراءات وأنهيتها
طلبوا منّي إبر
الإبر كانت طبعًا غير متواجدة ولا متوفرة
حسب الوزن.. وزنوا زوجي وقالوا:
أنه يحتاج على وزنه ثلاث إبر
الثلاث إبر لم أجدها للأسف في المستشفى
ولم تكن متوفرة، فاضطررنا
أدبرها من أماكن أخرى
ولكن بأسعار باهظة الثمن
هنا سؤال
طيب أنا لديّ ودفعت
وأنقذت زوجي من الموت المحتم
وكانت لديه أعراض بالرئة
دفعت وحصلت على الإبر والحمد لله والشكر
سؤالي هنا
وهذه رأيتها بأُم عيني في المستشفى
الناس الذين لا يملكون المال.. كيف؟
الذي لا يملك الإمكانية لدفع مبلغ الإبرة
كيف؟
يُسطرّ اسمه في عداد الموتى والوفيات؟
هو ايضًا بشر!
كيف؟
لا أريد أن أعيد وأقلّب المواجع
والأحزان
وسط هذه الأمور كلها، تم نسيان اللاجئ
وتاه بين الرجلين
فاللاجئ هو ايضًا بشر وإنسان
ويريد الحفاظ على نفسه
ويريد الحصول على علاج
تم نسيانه!
أصبح اللاجئ هو ايضًا المسكين
ضُمَّ صوته لصوت البشرية
أصبح هو كذلك يبحث عن كحول
هو ايضًا يريد الحفاظ على أسرته
وعلى أهل بيته
اسألكم سؤال وبأمانة
أريد جواب
انتم كشعب يعيش في بلده
أهله بجانبه، إخوتكم وجيرانكم بجانبكم
جيرانكم منذ طفولتكم معكم
هل شعرتم بخوف في هذه الفترة؟
هل شعرتم برُعب؟
ألم تبحثوا وتحضِروا وتخافون على أولادكم
لا تختلطون، لا تصافحون، لا لا..
حسنًا
كيف هذا اللاجئ؟
هذا اللاجئ الذي ترك بيته
وترك أهله وترك جيرانه
خرج مجرد نحن بالعراقي نقول
“عليجة على كتفه وطلع”
بـالمصري أو الآن عامة نقول
“الهاندباج وطلع بيها”
عَبَر بحار ومسافات وأميال
بحثا عن ماذا؟
ماذا يفعل؟
يريد أمان واستقرار لأطفاله
يريد النوم رغدًا كحالنا نحن الآن
ننام بدون صوت مدفعية ولا صوت دبابة
ولا صوت انفجار
ولا بتلك المنطقة انفجر
ولا هذا خُذ حذرك
هذا اللاجئ.. اللاجئ مجبور
اللاجئ إنسان مُسير وليس مخير
هذه الحروب التي حدثت
وهذه الأمور التي جرت بجميع الدول
هل سأله أحد؟
قال له هناك حرب بإحدى الدول
هل توافق على شنّها أم لا؟
هل استشاره أحد أو أخذه بعين الإعتبار؟
لا!
هو مجبور فقط لأنه خرج ليبحث عن
حياة كريمة وآمنة وعيشة لأبنائه
أنا لا أريد أن أُلقي اللوم على أي منظمة
ولا على أي جهة مسؤولة
ولا حتى على الإنسان
لا والله العظيم
أنا أحكي قصص واقعية رأيتها بعيني
وأحببت أن تتطلعون عليها
أحببت أنكم أنتم كشعب تحتضنون اللاجئين
تهونون عليهم المأساة التي عاشوها
تسهلون لهم أمرهم قدر الإمكان
أنا لن أقول لك تعال وحل الأزمة كلها
وحل أمور اللاجئين كلها.. لا
لكن لو أحد منّا مثلا
رأى أحد جيرانه محتاج
يقول له: تعال أنا فلان لديّ
مكان وأستطيع مساعدتك
أني مديرة مدرسة أقدر أساعدك
اتحدوا جميعكم مثل ما اتحدنا في كورونا
ألم نتحد؟
عندما كان ينتهي عندي الكحول، كانت
صديقتي المصرية تحضر لي برطمانات من الحكول
خذي تغريد، ضعيه للأولاد
لا يوجد هناك
لا مصري ولا عراقي
جميعنا نعيش وجميعنا مسلمين
ونعيش تحت علم مصر
جميعنا بحماية مصر وحفظها الله
وحفِظَ الشعب كله
شعب طيب وشعب لا يمكنكم تخيل الطيبة
التي لامسناها في قلوبهم
ولكن نقول
ما هو الدرس الذي نريد أن نتعلمه؟
هو أنه كما اتحدنا واتحد كل الكون في كورونا
دعونا نتحد في مساعدة اللاجئين
لن أقول لكم حلوا مشاكلهم جميعهم
لا
لكن
دعونا نُوَّصل صوتهم
دعونا نساعدهم بتوصيل
جزء من معاناتهم
لجميع الدول
قد لا يستطيع العالم حل هذه المشاكل
لكن في النهاية إن مجرد صوتهم يصبح مسموع
تحياتي لكم جميعا
وأعتذر إذا أطلت عليكم